ils ont repris en musique le chemin du
manège les huit écuyers et leurs chevaux
à nouveau réunis dans un ballet en
moutons et chorégraphié par bartabas le
spectacle la voie de l'écuyer existe
depuis 2003 mais chaque année il
s'enrichit au gré des envies et des
expériences de la compagnie
l'attelage c'est la grande nouveauté de
cette saison une discipline nouvelle
pour les chevaux et pour les écuyers il
leur a fallu un nom pour mettre ce
tableau en place il ya plus de
mouvements possibles les chevaux une
fois dressée peuvent pas fait pire
aurait été sous la voiture et est tourné
autour de son axe que peuvent pas faire
mais je peux normalement l'attelage donc
entre la construction des voitures le
adaptation du matériel qu'on a fait ici
sur place après un petit peu de temps
plus que de passage des chevaux qui est
la base d'attaché pas une discipline
particulière les figures de dressage
traditionnels comme le carrousel
lusitaniens sont toujours présentes
elle se mêle à d'autres disciplines
comme les scream le kyodo le tir à l'arc
japonais ou encore le champ il ya eu pas
mal d'évolutions dans les chorégraphies
que ce soit pour le travail aux longues
rênes le carrousel le trio après la
représentation les spectateurs se
pressent dans les écuries amateurs de
chevaux novices ils viennent parfois de
très loin pour voir le travail de
bartabas
j'ai réservé même billet sur tours elle
charrie ici exclusivement pour ça alors
si le spectacle vous tente les écuyers
leurs montures offre chaque week-end de
représentation le samedi à 18h ou le
dimanche à 15 heures